well hello there welcome to the Shan
method
I'm not Shawn I'm Shawn I'm here with
Shawn O'Dwyer I'm Chris McGinnis and our
filling in for Shawn McGinnis for his
live stream the Shawn method cuz once
again he's on his honeymoon what he said
I'm sort of selfish d BAE he died we're
just not telling you hey dad he got
murdered this week it's Red Dead
Redemption a far cry from what we played
last week all right you get one of those
cue that's that was it that was your one
guys it's cool just me and my bro me and
my buddy playing playing some games too
just messing around
yep don't start no stuff won't be no
stuff okay cool we'll see you later
whoa dude hey who's that dude oh he's
getting shot at Hey look you guys need
to cool it I think that's the police
whoops
you just killed the Popo yeah but I made
a friend can we get a high five no shoot
him in his eyes all you're gonna do
shoot him in his ankles so I call daddy
ankle Iser this guy is pretty this guy's
forgive and forget right now you don't
care you punch him all right
[ __ ] ahead punch oh yeah I'll do it
I saw can you drag him into the snake
yeah come over here all right come here
get off the road stop using the ditch to
your advantage you are remarkably clever
for a guy who just gets less owed time
and time again oh here we go yeah you're
in the snake now oh it's gonna bite your
crotch mission accomplished
Oh nature menaces to say may you rest
okay like a wasp wants you to start a
bar brawl he just works just murdered
that guy in the face
oh the other guy looks really bored by
his conversation I'm just doing him a
favor
just such a dick yeah don't Oh what are
you gonna do yeah give Belfast special
there he goes oh wow he's still what
over them yeah dealer jet it seems
pretty good it seems like we want to
find the bird you know the dude to chick
ratio hearing too good know this I mean
the Old West is like a known sausage
fest these guys are mad because they
don't think that I've brought party
favors but I did it's a fire bottle I
don't think so friend all right
hey yours is totally cool with my horses
used to you doing this [ __ ] all the time
so let's just let's just hang out at
camp now that's ducks dark
tumbleweeds this is a real picturesque
moment for a 15 day look at their
different murder hello friend nope nope
what did I do
those ways hit him gently what oh I got
sharp eyes Brogdon hello bro punching
people with guns is this mission repeat
cuz I remember doing yeah probably yeah
it's probably one of those just criminal
places that always has the crimes and it
Oakland don't worry I'll just cut I'm
just gonna cut you free I was gonna what
how do i how do I get down here oh man
he's really hoping really hand stab
downwards it's fine I'll figure this
we'll figure this out together
hurry hurry he's coming the friend is
coming
no I don't think I'm gonna make it you
dude he's invincible you can just
one-on-one with the dude oh this is kind
of good at on a horse can how you not
get on my horse when I'm super wasted my
horse is not having it I don't know if
this is actually affecting my horseback
riding though that is my horse Oh horse
bit less I'm Troodon oh I'm gonna try
off oh you can do it stay on the train
Marsten armadillo friend no wrong wrong
that dude don't be alone oh he looks
like he looks like a clicker now he
looks like a Harry's look at I made like
a horrible fungus growth from his brain
can I be at least dead long enough for
it to be daytime if not all just pitch a
tent I'm pitching a tent right now can
you shoot one of the horses and ride
with the other three four decides
dragged along for science ride wow these
guys are thieves really don't take
kindly to homeboy does quick escape now
my sea horses way decided to whoa this
is working remarkably well this is
actually happening I am affording the
river I've set out see I'm leaving land
behind in the new DLC I don't think
you're losing momentum but that's what
you do when you're on a boat at
nighttime you have a couple of drinks
okay don't get seasick no oh no oh gosh
nope you're still on it it go drop what
I'm made of sodium that's why boating
and alcohol don't mix facing the face in
the face in the face one shot in the
face once I face behind it's the best
nobody look at this one yeah eat it oh
how much fun that is I'm gonna blow out
your your ACL so you never need kilise
ten never gonna run the same again oh
yes you got him again oh you are never
going pro the shopkeeper has been killed
that shook he kicked himself in the face
you shuffle spewpa this guy's on the
snow he's gonna be sliding just fine yep
care if he's having a good time on the
water you're right that looks that did
not look as deepest but she disappeared
shoot this crate out of this tree yeah
murdered on doors so bad just no I'm not
going in that horse's skull Shawn I'm
gonna be back from the dead next week
wait wait wait Shawn is coming back from
his honeymoon next week and the Shawn
method is actually moving in time next
week it's not going to be Wednesday
morning at 11 a.m.
oh man it's gonna be Tuesday morning at
11 a.m. same time just one day earlier
in the week we're shifting around some
of our live shows so that we can you
know better distribute the hosts time
and I don't know basically at the end of
Tuesday I'm a worthless lump yeah as of
the lobby right now my cameras on
Wednesday now as well and we'll catch
you later bye